a little good news though let's finish
with this
wrong claim the outgoing chief of staff
for the White House gave a speech and it
made this uh they it's a video of him
giving a list of accomplishments of this
White House of this Administration and
uh it is when you hear it all at one
time it really does bring into Focus all
of the things that have gotten done even
with a Joe manchin and a Kirsten Cinema
standing in the way of some of the real
big progress things we could have gotten
done watch Ron Ron claim you've heard me
say this before but I never Tire of
saying it together we pass the largest
economic plan the most significant one
since FDR while managing the largest
land war in Europe since Truman
we passed the biggest infrastructure
Bill since Ike passed more judges than
any first year president than JFK and
the second largest health care bill
since LBJ the most significant gun
control Bill since Bill Clinton was
President and the largest climate bill
passed by any country at any time
anywhere on planet Earth all while
managing the worst Public Health crisis
any presidents faced since Woodrow
Wilson with the narrowest majority in
Congress of any new Democratic president
in a hundred years
[Applause]
massive it is impressive these things
did get done uh despite the efforts of
Republicans despite the efforts of the
independent now Kirsten Cinema and uh
Democrat
um from West Virginia Joe manchin does
he's a little out of breath there I mean
there's so many things to mention in so
little time he seemed out of breath it
reminds me it reminds me of that scene
from liar liar when Jim Carrey his
character gets pulled over by the cop
and then the cop just asked you know how
fast you were going or do you know why I
pulled you over
you know why I pulled you over depends
on how long you were following me
why don't we just take it from the top
here goes I sped I followed too closely
I ran a stop sign I almost hit a Chevy I
spent some more I failed to yield at a
crosswalk I changed lanes in the
intersection I changed lanes without
signaling while running a red light at
speeding
is that all no
I have unpaid parking tickets
yes
am I right or am I right Hey Ron clay
you know he's leaving the White House
it's a he could if they make a liar liar
too he he can he could play a role where
he says a bunch of words real quickly
and
out of breath anyway uh that is it for
me uh thank you guys for tuning in uh
I'd love to have you connect with me on
social media and here on YouTube out
there on the social media landscape I am
at dollar more just about everywhere and
right here on YouTube just search my
stupid name Jesse dollar more or dollar
more daily thanks a lot